[Music]
bonaparte's restaurant is in dire
straits
new owner suray has sunk everything into
it
it's frustrating the hell out of it
because i'm going nowhere the customers
are nowhere to be seen how many books
non-garden nothing at all no chances of
walking perhaps
the kitchen's down to two staff
and the money has nearly run out
i'm going in to identify the problems
[Music]
i'll find out if the market's there how
would you pay for that
if a team are pulling together take a
[ __ ] penalty and if the head chef is
cleaned up enough
you're taking the pistol you know
i've got just one week to turn this
restaurant into a viable business
honeymoon's over got to start making
profit now
[Music]
next to its posh neighbors ilkley and
skipton sid silvan
a little working class town yet to make
his mark on the cunnery map of britain
lots of
fish bars cafes quite a quaint little
place little small yorkshire town
bonaparte's wine bar and basement
restaurant on the high street was taken
over by its current owner just over a
year ago in her time sue ray has sold
everything from donkey rides to cavity
wall insulation
but the restaurant business is totally
new to her and so far the locals aren't
biting
good afternoon good afternoon sue it is
yes
please meet you likewise so how's it
going a bit quieter today how many did
you having for lunch about two two ready
that's it
and last night
last night i think we did only two again
that's all
two customers the whole because i missed
a whole night yeah unfortunately it's
just died of death
absolutely
the stark truth is that two-thirds of
russians don't survive past their first
birthday and as things stand sue's in
danger of adding to those statistics
as a last resort she's placed all her
trust in a 21 year old head chef
together they believe that fine dining
will guarantee bonaparte's a brighter
future
it's like being an artist you know i
mean you just start from from nothing
and create something so i think that's
why i love being a chef
from a humble start five years ago
washing dishes tim has had a meteoric
rise
obviously i would like a couple of
restaurants maybe three
being leeds in london new york you know
wherever just big cities you know so
that's my main ambition and obviously to
make a lot of money tim's ultimate dream
is to become a tv chef you put parmesan
for this stuff but for now he's
embracing his first opportunity to run
his own kitchen
how did you find tim uh he found me he
knew i'd been struggling with chefs and
uh lack of them
and he's very ambitious he must be
[ __ ] good if he's a head chef at 21
no either that or he's a [ __ ] good
bullshitter
pleasure to meet you sir likewise and
just pleasure lee lee so you're the head
chef yeah and you're the
well you're obviously gonna be the
second chef there's only two of you
busy lunch
no no absolutely not no i didn't think
so are you standing there twiddling your
thumbs
no
sue's food takings are a dismal 200
pound a week she should be clearing at
least 10 times that but she's not even
covering tim's wages let alone food
costs and overheads
chefs can't get excited unless there's
customers to cook for i'll never know
how good they are unless there's any
customers in the [ __ ] restaurant
uh tim hammy's booked
non-garden nothing at all no chances of
walk-ins perhaps
slim i want to see you on a little bit
of pressure tonight right it's five to
six
i want you to get out on the street
go knock on a few doors
and invite some locals to dinner get
your coats on and [ __ ] off for some
customers
if the customers won't come in off their
own free will these two young chefs are
going to have to go and drag them in
excuse me
we'd like to invite you for free fine
dining requires the ultimate in
presentation
[Music]
it's like a big cake you've got all the
ingredients
and you can mix it you're just going to
find like consistency to make it rise
your goal okay i'll see you there
the reputation of this place can't be
that great even with free food from the
fine dining menu on offer they've only
managed to pull in 11 guests
for any head chef this would be a walk
in the park
first order two pigeons main goals one
venice one bro
where do the tickets go um well i'll
just put them there because we never
really get enough to worry about it oh
[ __ ] me that's nice who's doing what
who's in the fish i'll do the fish what
would you like to do tonight uh
i'll do venison what i'm trying to say
is how the [ __ ] do you organize your
kitchen
take care of the hot starters i'll do
the cold stuff did you do the fish i'll
do the meat we jump
[Music]
within reason okay here we go where did
you put red bars
with the first orders in
now i can really see what's going on in
the kitchen
[Music]
what was that i just trashed a load of
balls
everybody's in the breakfast don't you
yeah
never mind fine dining they can't even
get the bread right it's [ __ ] frozen
get it back in the oven
are the pigeons ready yes we're about to
put them in the bin because the bread's
frozen pigeons are coot and the [ __ ]
bread's not even out there
and if you toss that [ __ ] cabbage
once more i'm gonna ram up your ass okay
can we yeah
everything you turn around
yeah let's go
even when the kitchen's busy you should
be looking to get the starters out
within 10 minutes of receiving the order
thank you very much these poor souls
have waited half an hour for the pigeon
breast with mushroom ravioli
and that's not the only problem
tim you made it over here yes
it's burnt can you not taste that man no
smell it
you honestly can't taste that burnt
but now you point it out yeah get that
[ __ ] a little bit
this is really worrying a head chef we
can't even taste his own foods burnt
he's not going to win any prizes for his
control of the kitchen either
and there's only two of them in here
can you hear oh no no no
buzzing the background that's the veg of
the microwave that should have gone with
the main course four minutes ago
come on tim get the [ __ ] things out
for some an hour's weight is just too
much
desperate to keep our staff costs down
sue has got a handful running the bar
upstairs and seems blissfully unaware of
the farce that's taking place in the
basement
kitchen's a disaster
a desire my disaster beyond belief the
blind leading the blind
the left arm not knowing what the right
arm is doing and you want 50 or 60 seats
filled
down there and they've got 11 customers
in
for dinner and up to eyeballs and
[ __ ]
i mean real [ __ ]
everything's going in these cutters for
some bizarre reason they think that
rings is the sort of ultimate
fine dining experience but it's superb i
don't understand what what the hell's
going on there
i don't know all i know is i'm not
making money
so i don't know what they're at or where
they're coming from
but it's sue's business and she should
be in charge
[Music]
look at the [ __ ] mess
huh
i've never seen such hard work for 11
guests
doesn't make you feel good does it no
not really
i've got just one week to make a
constructive impact on bonaparte
but by day two i'm clutching at straws
to find any positives to build on
sue lacks focus and has clearly lost
control
the kitchen's such a tip it's a health
hazard and worst of all the head chef
and his mate just aren't up to scratch
i must be missing something
um
gentlemen
tim sings a dish
scallops scarves can't wait to see it
nearly every successful resident has a
dish that is renowned for i'm hoping
that by cooking his tim will produce
something truly memorable something
truly worthy of a place on a fine dining
menu
that's your signature dish which is um
scallops with uh deep fried powder and
black pudding sauce hollandaise
certainly looks okay
what do you think
he's got to be sick
he's only gone and giving me a rancid
scallop
someone get him a drink
[ __ ]
how can you eat that
if you knew they were off what didn't
you say no i didn't
i didn't know they were off
they're [ __ ] minging
do not taste that
i do now yeah it took a while somehow
i know what it means i feel sick myself
now
it's um
it's grim
it's [ __ ] grim
and it's out of order
well i didn't realize you were [ __ ]
off
so
i suppose it's my fault really
i could kill some
that's the bottom line
in the two days i've spent at
bonaparte's i've witnessed total
incompetence in the kitchen
total lack of direction for the
management and last but not least
they've tried their best to kill me with
a rotten scallop
what the [ __ ] you playing at
sorry
well it's not about being [ __ ] sorry
you shouldn't be in a [ __ ] kitchen if
you don't know what's right and what's
wrong in that sense this is basic
[ __ ] cooking you know that
i need to check if there's any more
surprises lurking in tim's kitchen
there's a look in here
where are they from
uh saturday saturday would you use them
today no no what the [ __ ] they doing in
the fridge
it looks like rabbit [ __ ] that one
that's just some lentils
oh this one's stuck to the [ __ ] glass
it looks like sheep's turd that's been
infested with ants
we've got [ __ ] fur on [ __ ]
potatoes when's that from i can't tell
you
what we do with them
throw them in bin but you keep in the
fridge for two days before you throw
them in a bin
do you see what i'm trying to get at you
yeah does it make [ __ ] sense yes or
no no it's so this [ __ ] fridge is
jam-packed with [ __ ] and we're standing
here saying
i'll get them in the [ __ ] bin
this whole kitchen is disgustingly
filthy
in allowing things to fester tim's
putting sue's business at risk
can we get that one cleaned out as well
yeah
just one bad thing can contaminate a
whole fridge tim may as well just chuck
money out the window
a health inspector would have a field
day
you know what i'm [ __ ] gobsmacked you
know
i've got a good [ __ ] mind to get hold
of [ __ ] sue and just tell her to
[ __ ] close the place for me you know
that because this is the [ __ ] pits
you should be ashamed
rock bottom i've never seen anything
like this in my entire [ __ ] life you
know that because this is a [ __ ]
embarrassment
to catering
let alone [ __ ] ringed out fine dining
let's move her
not best start it could have been where
it to be honest
[ __ ]
like sorry
i saw it out
the pitch is becoming painfully clear
tim's completely unqualified to do this
job he's blagged his way in and sees
being naive enough to take him on
when you do put so much like
hard work into creating stuff and then
you know you don't use it you then you
get bored that's what i've done like
footballers playing with no football in
it they just run around what's point
will sit on their asses after a while or
they that's how it is
all this ingredients in there and no
customers to send it to
and yet none of them have been
communicating with each other you know
that's got to go tomorrow can we turn
that into a fish pie can we do something
with it but no they're blindly in the
blind and every bloody ingredient in
that fridge um is money your money
sue has no idea what's going on in her
own kitchen
key to any successful restaurant is
regular communication between management
and the head chef
i really need to get these two talking
everyone just had a word with me and
said
he's not very impressed
we need to keep the place
clean and everything tidy otherwise i
can be sued
in which case i'm out of business
and you're out of a job i realise yeah i
know and i've technically have to take
it on board as well
well i'll just have to stick her orange
she was gonna say i told you so but
that's what she was doing
yeah fair enough she had the little dick
solo
relations between tim and sue clearly
aren't healthy
lee
yeah goggles
gloves before we do any [ __ ] cooking
in here now i want the place absolutely
spotless goggles on please that's it
show me you handsome bastard
it's not just the kitchen there's a
thought here
any clued up restauranteur knows it's
damn stupid to attempt fine dining in a
basement let alone one that's beneath a
busy bar
[Music]
sue's panic is obvious when you see the
weird mix of fine dining menus and
scrappy handwritten boards advertising
tv named cabarets
bonaparte's image has clearly confused
potential customers she was trying to
think to do too many things to be all
things to all people
so she was trying to have you know live
music and have an internet camera
and uh
also the impression that you got when
you came in was she'd be shuffling
around in her leggings and her slippers
i don't think she's gonna attract the
people that she wants to attract
it's not as nice as the one that started
to cross the road
the newly opened competition just 200
yards away has been fully built since it
opened so the bundles are definitely out
there
it's time to find a clear identity for
bonaparte and make a clean start
valentine's night is just four days away
it's one of the most important nights of
the russian calendar and it can make or
break a new venture
if we're going to reinvent bonaparte's
image we've got to do it now
but we'll sue accept the drastic change
of direction i'm about to propose
[Music]
it's clearly
not going to work as a fine dining
experience does tim know how much
pressure you're under financially i say
flippantly you know i'll end up going
bankrupt if you're not careful but it
doesn't realize how true that is yeah
may have close eye
in real terms in real terms
um probably
i've got probably
three months
maximum jesus
you know i'm willing to take
constructive criticism it's not working
is it otherwise we'd have more people in
the basics are wrong i mean the
basics are so so wrong and it's you know
it's embarrassing it's gonna go back to
comfort rustic
easy-going food it's gonna become more
of a bistro because the place oozes that
kind of style
i know sue's convinced but if i'm to
flush out tim's pretensions to fine
dining once and for all i need to
provide him with evidence that he can't
fail to take on board
gentlemen tim
right this is a sea of scallops with a
uh baby block put in with a nice
hollandaise km pepper sauce and a bit of
deep fried parmesan it looks like potato
but i'm not sure first time you had a
scallop
and this is a beef and all pie
i love it i'm a fashion man
yeah beautiful the scallops and the
black pudding and the parmesan
how much you pay for that well i wanted
to pay a lot what do you mean
well i don't know
anyway aren't there so 850 850.
what about
and what would you pay for the pie oh my
eight pound about eight pound
seven ninety five oh i'm not far off an
8.95 well done
which one would you prefer well i like
the pie personally well i like the me
and the left field there mate
thank you gentlemen thank you one nil
you [ __ ]
tim needs to learn a few basic russian
rules
if you don't know your market you'll
never get bums on seats i would probably
go with this one
two [ __ ] nil next please oh you got
two seconds here's another one have you
got two seconds russians without
customers will go bust
you don't like scallops
excuse me
put another way
tim needs to start producing food the
people of silson won't be able to resist
that is gorgeous
you wouldn't pay 8.95 for that in the
major cities yeah i'd expect to but that
is very good
very reasonable and delicious
are you listening i am listening be true
that's where we're going yeah fine
dining
who's going in for it
it's not bad news you know that it's
[ __ ] good news
yeah and it's it's it's clearer
the writing's on the wall
she's come the end of the title up there
that's pretty obvious that yeah she's
she's had enough huh yeah is that clear
yeah it's clear yeah and you know
you're [ __ ] cocky with her you know
that yeah yeah and she pays your [ __ ]
salary are you mad how much have you put
in here
yeah not a [ __ ] penny
not a single penny but you've taken from
haven't you yep so now it's time to give
back absolutely definitely and not
cooking for egos get rid of it
back to basics you know that
what i want you two to do just to
confirm that you do know the basics both
at the same time cook me a [ __ ]
omelet
show me something that i can eat
and be happy with
anomaly is probably one of the first
things you learn to cook at catering
college
was last time cooked only and cooked one
before
i've known i've never cooked an omelette
before
oh don't be stupid
look inside
what is that telly
um
slightly overcooked
slightly
it tastes like [ __ ] rubber i'm both
overcooked
that was [ __ ] by any standard
you're a head chef
you're taking the picture you know that
you are taking the piss you know that
yes carter
gives you nothing back
and the whole idea of telling him off is
to sort of help train him and educate
him but
clearly
not used to being told what to do
right make me another omelette [ __ ] it
let's go
any chef worthy salt should be able to
source good quality ingredients at a
good price
the locals already think bonaparte's is
too expensive
they want value for money
for su to start making any sort of
profit tim needs to be clever about what
he buys
i have two bank assemblies please and
two cups of tea
he needs to wake up to the real world
he's clearly in need of some inspiration
for his new bistro style menu thanks
donnie thank you that's your on that one
don't spill it on those new trainers
will you no try not to the chinese
tongues tonight we've got a table of
four in i want you
okay
dubai
starter main course and pudding 20 quid
5 quid per head right i want to see how
clever you are with that money right
[Music]
good morning
good morning
i'm making french onions
right we're making some french onion
soup today so
we're looking for some like sort of
rustic like baguettes
[Music]
clearly tim's never bought anything from
a market before in his life
discount for the trade
any discount for the trade
it's always worth before you know that
so when you're on the telephone in the
morning you're checking with your
suppliers and you want to know how much
the fish is you can always bargain with
them i bet you don't seize money this
way do you
i will do from now on [ __ ] right you
will
tim's menus are packed with expensive
fish and meat cuts he needs to open his
eyes to the tasty less expensive options
on offer
yeah
what's that next to the pig's head
what is that there
um
that's oxtail oxtail you ever used
oxtail before no what would you do with
a braising steak
i don't know really maybe barbecue it's
quite nice on barbecue you know and when
she gets them going raisin steak means
[ __ ] braising
so it's telling you what to do with it
so what would you do with it where is it
like a stew
you can't put it on the [ __ ] barbecue
just looking for some chicken breasts
it's a nice pretty blessing yes
thank you i love you it's nice check it
out have a look
how much is it
how much is chicken per breast
is it your butcher's more expensive yeah
jesus
four of them please any uh discount for
trade just call for trade how much was
it
you'd come again absolutely the more
they see you the more banter you have
with them the more bargains you get with
them and the cheaper it becomes yeah
yeah
oh definitely then the restaurant starts
to make a bit of [ __ ] money yeah
get the picture yeah i get it thanks for
that
how much we spend
just over 12 quid 12 quid fantastic for
four portions brilliant okay french on
your suit it costs 75 pence to make a
portion okay how much does it go on the
menu for
you times by four and that should cover
everything 295 for a bowl of soup and
we've made money on that and one thing
we're not going to do with ingredients
we bought this morning is waste anything
we waste nothing
with the valentine's extravaganza just
two days away i'm under no illusions as
to what we're up against [ __ ] limp
dick in the kitchen you know give you
some [ __ ] energy [ __ ] 21 for god's
sake you should be getting [ __ ] 12
hard-ons a day
not one a [ __ ] month
let's go lee's got a bit of now like
whis i've got to hold tim's hand every
step of the way
are you sure you want to be a chef
yes you are yeah in right into the
center this is our one chance to see if
tim can cope with his new bistro style
food turn the knife out
put it back in
and bring it to the
edge there yeah
yep
gently gently
gently
make love to it don't [ __ ] it
outside leaves
yeah what do you do with them you throw
them away yeah we usually throw them
away
but before we let him loose on the pain
customers i've asked him to cook for
four special people in the privacy of
their own home
well i haven't told him it's for his own
family
he's like stir it into it hard no you
leave it dangling on top so it gets
perfect of course you let it [ __ ]
stir inside
we've got soup chicken lemon pie yeah
let's go and surprise mom dad shall we
let's go around to their house
and you cook their tea okay create a
juice sauce for the chunky
um
[Music]
i don't i don't know i'm asking you yeah
i don't i don't think so good because
the center is is the sauce the garlic
sauce is
hello madge how are you surprised i hate
to use tim's folks as guinea pigs but
with the three-course meal already
prepared
all tim needs to do is reheat the soup
and cook the kievs
so we get cracking where's granddad
this should be a walk over even for him
he was always in the kitchen as a boy
wanting to help bake because he loves
talking about it doesn't he yes
yeah
but then he decided whilst he was at
school that that's what he wanted to do
and he got himself a job in the kitchen
and it just went on from there told me
that he was going to be a chef and he
was going to the good food show to meet
gary rhodes and off he went
fantastic look what's happened yeah
burn it don't burn it
here we go
sorry keep you waiting that's quite all
right he's ready
let's not forget tim is a head chef
[ __ ] it oh
whoops
burnt my pants have you
don't forget your croutons
he's managed to [ __ ] them with his
grands house
ladies first
this is some french onion soup
minus the croutons
what we're gonna do with this num fun
ah look at that
superb torched on the outside and pink
in the middle
as for the lemon meringue pie you would
get a better reception if you threw it
tim's family wouldn't dream of
criticizing him but the paying customers
on valentine's night won't be as
forgiving
we've got 44 books for saturday night
and you [ __ ] it for four
what chance have you got for 44.
now starting to [ __ ] myself
it's my fourth day at bonaparte's
tim's first attempt at cooking a
simplified bistro meal may have
impressed his granny but he and i both
know the awful truth
it was a spectacular flop
you paid as a head chef aren't you
yeah
do you think you should be a head chef
not really thank [ __ ] for that
don't start crying i'm not well you look
you're about to [ __ ] bubble
okay so you're delighted with that
bookings for tomorrow night valentine's
cabaret are piling in
with the restaurant nearly booked to
capacity i'm trying my hardest to stay
positive that's fine mr lowe i'm sure
you'll enjoy it
but with just a day to go it'll take
more than high energy drinks for these
two to put it off
when someone's been told off the first
thing you do in a kitchen is come back
at 100 mile now and
this guy disintegrates every time you
tell him something he just disappears
into oblivion
and loses all sense of concentration
that little short span that he has why
don't you swap the rolls around tomorrow
why don't you become the sous chef and
lee becomes the head chef for tomorrow
night
no answer
whatever you want to do it's your
[ __ ] kitchen
you're supposed to say bollocks no i'm
the [ __ ] chef my name's tim graham
he's me on the menu no
yes or no
yes
maybe it's me i should try the softly
softly approach
we've got a big night saturday night
it's full yeah and it's the first time
since you've both been here that the
place is full
okay and whilst i'm here you're not
shafting me as well at the same time you
know that yeah we're gonna work together
over the next 15 20 minutes i want you
both to think of something really simple
menu wise three starters three main
courses and three puddings one
definitely soup
yeah by passing some of the decision
making back to tim i'm hoping to build
up his confidence and instill some pride
in his food it's hard to write a simple
menu when you've had your head up your
ass for so long
doing trying to make
fancy silly food that's the kind of
stuff we're going for in it so
up
main classes living onions mashed potato
macaroni cheese fish and chips mushroom
peas lemon shot what
language hot pot that sounds nice
can you come up with the ideas together
yeah we'll just flick through some books
and thought what what's simple and um
you know basically thought what did we
used to have at school what did we like
at school and i'm not forgetting where
are we
in yorkshire
in devising this new menu i'm aiming to
take most of the pressure off tim and
lee during service
ninety percent of the food can be
prepared and perfected a day in advance
let's go see if you can show me you can
handle two pans at once as long as it's
made well they can't fail to be a hit
with the customers
there should be 15 things going on there
all the same time coordination
understanding medium
pink is it well done onions roasted
in short bonaparte's new bistro menu is
designed to be idiot-proof
definitely
identify them as vegetarians yeah let's
go come on
[Music]
so far tim's attitude towards soon has
been that of a stroppy teenager rather
than a respectful and supportive
employee i'm gonna go on um tomato soup
rustic tomato soup yeah yeah some little
uh cheese that's probably a first it's
actually come to us i've had to run down
and chase all the time
and then i need this and then oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah it'll come late i said i
need it now basically you just put them
through some butter
crush them up
today seems a lot better i don't know
what he's been doing to him down there
but he's certainly improving
in the week i've been here i've hardly
seen tim or lee sample or season
anything they've made
no wonder their tasteless food is
failing to woo the customers everything
we do
in this kitchen has to be tasted i don't
care if it's a [ __ ] bread roll
a lemon meringue pie or a chicken kiev
you have got to start tasting things
from now on bland is off the menu
and to teach these two a lesson they'll
never forget i'm resorting to dirty
tactics
you know what a medium steak tastes like
yes
does that taste like a
sirloin t-bone steak or is it a rump
steak
a sirloin sirloin
it tastes like salad
[ __ ] your meal here we go now for the
cake
open up okay tell me whether it's medium
or is that well done medium
and long well done none of you got that
right
yes yes
pork and [ __ ] lamb [ __ ] it now you
don't you don't realize until someone
blindfolds and feeds you
that your palates are
not active
could have been worse
could have been chicken
then we wouldn't look like [ __ ]
idiots
oh [ __ ]
tim's had a week of non-stop grief from
me
wait wait
this boy has really tested my patience
all right how do we know they're ready
now
you can lift them upside down yeah there
you go
and i really don't know if any of it
sunk in
do well i'd love to just get it
but with more than 40 guests expected in
just over two hours time he'll soon be
tested to his absolute limits
i slipped no no don't tell me it was the
mud
[Laughter]
can't even take a [ __ ] penalty i'll
say this for tim he's no quitter and i
don't want to see him fail but now he's
got to prove he's master of his own
kitchen we're not leaving this there's a
draw you know that
hey
in cooking
nobody draws ever one thing's for sure
tonight he'll either sink or swim
[Music]
another two upstairs
possibly okay good news good news
another two so we're up to 50 48 now
sue's never had so many bookings she's
having to move furniture out
to fit more tables in
you happy with that
chicken kiev we roasted vine tomatoes
t-bone stay with homemade chips
because there's so many involved for
dinner i wouldn't stall them upstairs
for too long you're really going to dump
us in it big time prawn cocktail three
bean salad with mustard dressing what do
you think
[Music]
i hardly dare say it but this place has
got a real buzz about it
there's one thing missing
what do you like on all your menus
oh
bingo
we work as a team and it's a giant
effort and bistro
you know that's it that's the most
central thing you've said to me all
[ __ ] wii you know that
thank
you
every decent restaurant in the country
is full on valentine's night
the competition down the road is packed
to the rafters
and for once so is bonaparte's
in a small town like silson business
thrives on word of mouth
and if tonight's a disaster it could
break soon i have got a fear that he
will
not be able to cope with the numbers
especially when he's saying that 11's
busy
i don't think so
so we'll see what it's made of
tim has got to get this right
stairs two soup two chicken okay hey
six o'clock first order's in
okay
hello chef yes well
why is it give it to scott scott first
order in
hey are we going to let the kitchen
border call out the tickets or are you
going to call them out come on
another two soup two chicken one creme
brulee one treat called top blue
let's go soup's made get on to boil
starting put some water in it
please
something's burning what's that burning
it's just on the air it's on the grill
thing it's not the croutons there no
it's not the crew on don't burn the
croutons i'm not burning
not yet
i think we should put the pan on first
yeah start the chicken and as they're
eating the soup the chicken's cooking
yeah
[Music]
are you all right yeah yeah first order
it's upstairs you're okay well the pan's
not on for the chicken yeah
don't burn the croutons
okay
all right how long for that soup
[Music]
45 seconds
i'll [ __ ] off
hey
what the [ __ ] are you doing by the way
young man
what are you doing
slow down talk to him
lee can you send the two suit please
wait
look at the croutons
charcoal again
oh god it's the first [ __ ] order
what's the matter nothing
no well you're you're cooking like an
absolute [ __ ] you know that yeah just
take your time
big deep breath and talk to lee a little
bit you're just on your own spinning
around round and round and just creating
a [ __ ] bedroom yeah calm down get
yourself organized yeah and control
yourself now [ __ ] come back to me a
little bit come back to me a bit yes
go on timmy fresh start or we're going
to go down like a sack of [ __ ]
that's better lee look at him look hey
nice and bright give us a smile
it's well done isn't it yeah yeah come
on in
[Music]
team work
two minutes or some eventually
scotty can have two ovals out of there
mate please
on order three prong cocktail one suit
one sirloin medium one t-bone medium one
sirloin medium so don't rush the stars
got a lot of stuff to get on here
communicate good
starting as soon as you get some smaller
damage
how long for vegeta
[Music]
[Music]
well done
one lemon one brulee
all right scotty to what i can have
there two ovals on me please
good
that's it now you talk to the whole
brigade now
now you're talking to the team which is
fantastic keep it going yes
can you stop
talking we're gonna go we're gonna go
down yeah yeah
hey it's not quite right but at least
it's moving yeah yeah
medium with salad that's a medium on
itself without salad and that's a rare
yeah without salad
give it together yeah yeah yeah let's
not get nervy thing was
was excellent
yeah very enjoyable it's what we
expected to have really it's really
tasty and
really enjoyable it's nice how many more
to come please sue uh there's another
four four i over booked actually the
local competition tonight it's got 46
built if we do this last four we've
beaten them yeah what is it yeah does
that not just lift the morale up a
little bit absolutely
several media medium medium medium and
cheap that isn't done
please uh scotty take it away
one t-bond medium and one chicken kia
please and that's all going to table
12.
please
put a program together
watch the color look when it's brown
it's cooked when it's black it's booked
[Music]
what's a pastry please
pies veg first veg
[Music]
[Music]
not finished yet but yeah well done
[Music]
tim graham and grandad are celebrating
their 44th wedding anniversary
at last tim can repay them for the
rubbish he served up a couple of nights
ago with a delicious welcome meal
[Music]
it was lovely that thing it was
beautiful
[Music]
did it yeah hey do you hear what
granddad said yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
did you really surprise me tonight and
i'm really seriously over the moon that
you didn't [ __ ] it i'm serious sir yeah
because the first 15 minutes of six
o'clock you actually like the biggest
twenty in britain you know that
all over the shop and you pulled it back
together and that wasn't me that was you
and the feedback from them out there has
been brilliant what does that tell you
what does that what does that put in
there i had a service like that for a
long time and these stupid [ __ ]
illusions of grandeur all this stupid
fine dining crap that you're trying to
do
it's gone
do you understand yeah exactly where you
are now yeah yeah totally do you
understand what you're capable of doing
within this restaurant yes stop trying
to take it beyond something it's never
going to be
you'll [ __ ] the restaurant and you'll
[ __ ] yourself
big time
to never forget tonight
it's up to you now not to
allow it
i also think you've been confused to
what you want
because you haven't been focused on one
direction for the restaurant because
you've been
jumping
all over and that's part of a panic yeah
and that's right
and now tonight clearly evident exactly
what you need to do from this day
onwards
and if he changes anything i'll pick his
nuts when i arrived at bonaparte a month
ago it literally had no customers
head chef tim gray was a liability
i didn't realize you were [ __ ] off
he couldn't even cook an omelette you're
taking the pistol you know
in one grueling week we transformed
bonaparte from a failing fine dining
restaurant into a buzzing bistro
with tim sending out quality food to
nearly 50 contented customers on
valentine's night
but since i left sue's given tim two
written warnings over his attitude
now i'm back unannounced to find out
what is going
that on thing off my god
what's going on
chilling
chilling
it's friday night it's 7 30. how many's
booked four four and you've got the
music blaring away yeah i'm just wesley
he's upstairs i'm back he's in a bar
what the [ __ ] is that in there muscles
you're not serving them are you yeah
what the fridge is like
oh my god oh my what is that [ __ ] in
there
there's mold and fur
dear oh dear so you haven't changed have
you
oh [ __ ] you now
a whole week drumming into their thick
skulls and it comes to this holy [ __ ]
this is a living [ __ ] nightmare
nobody in this place is taking control
and in this state a health inspector
would close them down without a second
thought
so i've got to show you this because
it's part of your
responsibility and this is your gaff
there you go
you didn't see this no i didn't actually
in fairness to tim he was he was doing
okay it seemed to be okay for the first
three days then it went from there this
is not right this is this is [ __ ]
miles away this is a nightmare you know
that because it's more loss on top of
more loss and more loss and more mold
that's what worries me because you need
to touch that
you need to rub your finger on that you
need to go to a chip you need to season
something you put your finger in the
tomato soup and then they're all [ __ ]
you've just contaminated the whole place
and that's what really worries me this
kitchen is not fit to cook a [ __ ]
thing in right now
and that's your problem
okay i think i better just close
and put due to refurbishment
and you should burn out gracefully yeah
just been giving him another chance and
another chance
that's that's i can't tolerate that it's
just going to end up but
it's professional suicide isn't it
he's congley as simple as that
i don't honestly think
he did it deliberately i don't think
he's a nasty piece of work i just think
he lives in a walter mitty world i begin
to think that he's just convinced
himself to be
honest to go from
valentine's day
evening
to this is
it's not even funny there's just
something wrong with it
valentine's day look good man i don't
think i've gone home to bed or whatever
feeling in a better
happier state of mind
and tonight i don't think i could go to
bed in a worse one
just beyond recognition really anyhow
[ __ ] stupid that
someone could be you know i mean
it's a dog one
and who is that someone too no that
would be me
pretty much
yeah
at least the bar's busy that is one
saving grace but really
thank god she closed that kitchen down
because it was [ __ ] disgusting i mean
really appallingly bad
shockingly bad
just let me get on with it
it'd be a damn sight let you get on with
it this floor being needy in sh1t well
before you rang me up all aggressive i
would get in on me you're fine i was
respecting you and
giving it all the like gentlemanly
bloody stuff i could do and then you
went and shot it down [ __ ] pan no
don't turn it on me if a floor is filthy
before
it doesn't matter anymore what's filthy
it doesn't matter yes i think it does i
think we've established that look
yeah
[ __ ] the [ __ ] fly that's worse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you